mom
no
just one no sorry kourtney kardashian's
kids aren't exactly fans of their mom's
over-the-top pda with husband travis
barker and now e.t is learning new
details about their blended family
specifically why court's kids feel
overwhelmed by their mom's new marriage
i love the idea of a blended family i
think that you know the more kids the
merrier courtney shares three kids with
ex scott disick twelve-year-old mason
nine-year-old penelope and
seven-year-old reign the reality star
tied the knot with travis in italy over
the weekend and though it's only been a
few days as husband and wife a source
tells e.t their marriage has been an
adjustment for the kiddos and they are a
little overwhelmed by the pda and media
attention in fact fans even caught a
glimpse of the kids cringing on a recent
episode of the kardashians
mom
just one no sorry yeah so p was not here
for her mom's affection towards trav and
like his sister raine gets grossed out
by it too
i'm gonna die
you guys okay
you guys please not french kid
no fridge kissing baby okay so what do
travis's kids think of everything our
source says things have been a little
easier on their end travis has three
kids with ex-wife shayna mookler
twenty-three-year-old auntiana
eighteen-year-old landon and 16 year old
alabama you know my main concern is
always you know my children are my first
priority and you know that's one thing
that you know travis and i you know do
agree on it's probably the only thing we
agree on but you know our children come
first and their happiness and as long as
you know the kardashians are good to my
kids you know that's all that matters to
me as a mom you know as long as they're
happy and then you know that's that's
the key the source goes on to say that
they are excited to have courtney as
their stepmom and absolutely love her
everyone is working through this new
chapter together as a unit and of course
courtney and travis want their kids to
feel comfortable and happy we're just
you know living our best lives
yeah
but it turns out when it comes to scott
mason penelope and reign are still very
protective of their dad our source says
since there is still some animosity on
scott's part it's been a work in
progress on tuesday scott reunited with
his kids after they returned home from
the wedding in italy he shared this shot
of rain sleeping with the caption i got
my baby and this blurry selfie featuring
penelope and mason he writes got my crew
with me i think you just gotta
figure out really what's important to
you at the end of the day but don't
worry because the source adds at the end
of the day the little ones are happy
they are glad to see their mom so over
the moon and in love
[Music]